bonjour bienvenue avec nous sur rt
france alors on en a beaucoup en des
chiffres pour illustrer à quel point la
faim tue dans le monde
en tout cas un constat la faim dans le
monde s'est aggravée en 2020 quels sont
les pays les plus concernés
une bonne partie de ce que vous venez de
citer
il ya une forme chronique il faut se
rendre compte
ça ça paraît à peine croyable mais il ya
autant de gens qui ont faim aujourd'hui
qu'en 1908 1950 c'est à peu près 800
millions de personnes qui se couchent le
soir avec le mal aux ventes en disant
j'ai pas assez mangé comment je fais
pour manger demain à l'intérieur de ces
800 millions de personnes il ya les gens
qui sont vraiment en menaces de mort
immédiate c'est-à-dire tout proche de la
famille et tout ça ça s'aggrave avec les
3 c que nous dit oxfam les conflits le
réchauffement climatique
le climat est le co vide alors
typiquement à madagascar c'est y a pas
d'état comme y'a pas d'état il n'ya pas
d'agriculture efficace et en plus un
pays tropical qui est très menacée par
le réchauffement climatique et les
cyclones et les sécheresses etc
donc ça s'aggrave alors ensuite vous
avez montré le sahel et le et le sud
soudan ben là c'est la guerre mais
quelque part la guerre elle vient aussi
du réchauffement climatique
c'est à dire plus le sahel se transforme
en sarre 1 il pleut de moins en moins
dans le sahel
les gens se regroupent de plus en plus
il n'y a pas assez à boire et y'a pas
assez à manger du coup l'agriculture
n'est pas bonne
il trouve toujours un prétexte pour se
taper dessus et donc c'est une zone qui
est maintenant guerre chronique le sahel
une zone de 5000 km de long sur sur 1000
km de hauteur
bon eh ben
effectivement dès qu'il ya un petit
facteur aggravant mais ça marche quoi je
veux dire nous en roulant 4,4 faut pas
se plaindre si avocat ram le dire la
réalité c'est que la planète se
réchauffe et quand on n'a plus rien à
boire et plus rien à manger on trouve
toujours un prétexte pour se battre et
puis il ya une autre loi c'est que même
les peuples comme se payer une
kalachnikov
alors ensuite effectivement ça s'aggrave
or encore plus avec le co vide est ce
que ben les communications
internationales sont plus difficiles la
générosité et plus et des moins bonnes
et donc quand on ajoute le co lead plus
le réchauffement climatique plus
l'inefficacité économique de
l'agriculture bat effectivement ce
chiffre augmente alors il ya une
stabilité considérable de ce chiffre
depuis un siècle
mais à l'intérieur de cette stabilité
nous sommes en période de crise et donc
il faut se rendre compte que en europe
plus personne n'a fin il ya de la
pauvreté mais plus personne a faim on
parle bien d'un monde dans lequel il ya
un enfant de moins de cinq ans qui
meurent de faim toutes les dix secondes
toutes les dix secondes et l'amène oxfam
novib c'est plus toutes les dix secondes
c'est toutes les cinq secondes
on va avoir un mort de faim dix morts de
faim à la minute au lieu de cinq morts
de faim la minute soit finalement on
meurent plus de faim que de guerre en
meurent plus de faim que de co vite sur
cette planète sauf que c'est une mort
silencieuse c'est la mort de jean
isolées dans des villages isolés du
terme ont alors beaucoup de facteurs
pour expliquer à la fin d'un monde bien
évidemment l'onu s'étaient fixés comme
objectif d'éradiquer cette faim dans le
monde
en 2030 on a bien compris que c'est un
objectif qui ne sera pas atteint mais
quand ça a été mis sur la table cet
objectif qu'est ce qui a été fait
justement en ce sens pour l'atteindre
m'écouter sur le fond le problème il est
d'abord agricole il faut se rendre
compte que depuis 1900 on a augmenté de
6 milliards le nombre de gens sur la
planète on est passé d'un milliard 8 à 7
milliards 8
il ya toujours 800 millions champions
fin alors on peut regarder les choses de
façon optimiste on a réussi à nourrir 6
milliards de gens de plus sur les mêmes
chances c'est quand même pas rien parce
que c'est les même si on n'a pas fait
une nouvelle planète et c'est bon on
défriche comme des malades la forêt
tropicale mais à l inverse on good run
on on organise à peu près autant donc on
cultive toujours à peu près la même
surface
bon donc d'un côté on a réussi à faire
une amélioration considérable de
l'agriculture mais cette amélioration
elle s'est cantonnée dans des sommes
relativement privilégiés l'europe de
l'ouest l'amérique du nord le brésil
l'argentine et puis il ya plein
d'endroits qui sont restés en dehors de
cette révolution verte et notamment
l'afrique l'asie a réussi par exemple la
chine a réussi à augmenter
considérablement sa production agricole
mais pas l'afrique
donc d'un côté on peut se dire qu'il ya
encore des réserves de productivité
gigantesque en afrique si on veut bien
si au lieu de se faire la guerre ce
fichu on se met à faire vraiment de
l'agriculture l'afrique peut produire
beaucoup plus le problème c'est que
c'est plus difficile maintenant
pour deux raisons d'une part il ya le
réchauffement climatique qui rend le
l'agriculture beaucoup plus difficile
dans les pays tropicaux et d'autre part
il ya l'agriculture moderne entre
guillemets tout chimie tout pétrole ça
marche au début
par exemple en france ça marchait du feu
de dieu des années 60 aux années 90
on a triplé la productivité agricole ont
produit trois fois plus de blé à
l'hectare que dans les années 60
le problème c'est qu'au bout d'un moment
les inconvénients de cette politique
rattrape les avantages et qu'on a de la
pollution de la baisse de la
biodiversité de la baisse de la
fertilité et c est du coup par exemple
en france
le rendement du blé a augmenté
massivement à tripler des années 60 aux
années 90 et ça fait 30 ans qu'il
n'augmente plus parce que les
inconvénients de cette politique ont
rattrapé les avantages donc maintenant
non seulement il faut produire plus
malgré le réchauffement climatique mais
faut produire avec une nouvelle
révolution agricole il faut produire par
des méthodes agroécologiques et non plus
par des méthodes chimiques qui montre
aussi leurs limites
c'est donc le problème il est
considérable et il faut beaucoup de
mobilisations et quelque part le on va
dire les pays riches regarde ailleurs si
ça leur problème finalement les pays
riches qu'on ait faim en eau sont au
soudan du sud en haïti est versée
science et voilà isolement qui fait
qu'on les laisse mourir de faim monsieur
par entier merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions on est pris par
le temps je rappelle que vous êtes
conférence est consultant spécialisé
dans les questions agricoles merci à
vous